hello
yeah listen
uh
we [ __ ] up
hey good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever you are i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
it's april 11 2022 we're live streaming
on rumble youtube and blaze tv
subscribe get some notifications see
what happens
for the record
i chose to bleep that cold open clip
right there it was my decision to bleep
the f-bomb i did not want to start
the week off i did not want to say this
is monday let's do something funny let's
just jam an f-bomb right in their face
but yes he does say the f-bomb there i
just thought it was a nice funny way to
start the week and uh and we got a heck
of a week around here because if you did
not know if you've been living under a
rock
i've got a book coming out tomorrow
that's right people don't burn this
country is officially out tomorrow if
you order it today on amazon you can
still get it tomorrow and i've been told
several people in the reuben report
locals community have told me that their
books have arrived already
no spoilers people okay because there's
a lot of info in there we can't have it
leaking out today so books are arriving
today i've seen some people tweet it at
me as well you can get your copy at
davereuben.com
book
and we are we're burning up the charts
already do we have some of those charts
that's right right now in political
freedom we're number one and number two
number one is the audiobook we crush it
on the audio side because you people are
tech savvy people you like to hear the
audio book while you're multitasking
maybe you're running walking the dog
whatever it is that you're doing maybe
you're having marital relations while
listening to me i don't know what you're
doing number two over there is the
regular hardcover and then also not just
political freedom we've got civil rights
and liberties we are now number one and
uh that's gotta be a real shame if you
are uh over at number four there the
book
anti-racism cookbook handbook
don't buy that that's not good uh and
real quick guys i am going on tour it
starts next tuesday in west palm beach
with donald trump jr and we're bouncing
all over the place
you know it already couple vip seats
left uh and general admission tickets
are available you can go to
davereuben.com
events every single
show will be completely different so if
you want to come to all the shows you
will see a different show every single
night i promise you and if you get a vip
ticket as you know you get the one
second hug
all right real quick so today we are
going to be talking about how this
country actually is burning and the
people who are igniting the fire and
pouring gasoline on it tomorrow since
the book is coming out tomorrow i'm
going to go into a little more in depth
of how we can fight back i think i've
been hinting out some ideas but that's
really what the book is about and i do
believe we can fight back we can fight
back we can separate there's a whole
series of things that we can do to get
control over our lives as these people
do burn the country but before i do that
one story that broke last night
bizarrely at 11 p.m on sunday night
was that the ceo of twitter
parag agrawal i hope i'm getting his
name right announced he released a
statement at 11 o'clock on sunday night
which all you have to know before i even
say anything else when you release a
press release at 11 o'clock on sunday
night something ain't right something's
a little fishy uh he released a press
release that elon musk is actually not
going to be taking the board seat on
twitter remember last week elon musk
bought 9.2 percent of twitter that's
obviously not a majority stake but he
was the largest single shareholder in
twitter all week long he was tweeting
about changes that might actually take
place at twitter then they announced he
was going to have the board seat well
now the board seat ain't going to happen
which is interesting at many levels
we'll talk about it more throughout the
week but it's it's right in the
wheelhouse of everything that's
happening with big tech and free speech
and all sorts of stuff maybe he started
you know really uh pushing on hey guys
what about the biden laptop story what
happened there i'd like some info on
that maybe he said hey i want to get
orange man back on the platform the
whole company freaked out and i will
just add one other thing to this which
is i've been told
uh this morning
that apparently if he was to sit
on the board he would only be able to
buy another 5
or so of twitter it would be about 14
point something percent but now as a
non-board holder he could actually
engineer a hostile takeover of the
entire company so something interesting
is going down and i just want to leave
that there for now we'll find out more
throughout the week and we're just going
to talk this week about or today we're
just going to talk about just the usual
cast of characters fouchy's back gay
pete confused joe crazy kamala they're
all back they're all back over the
weekend sake all of them and uh we're
gonna uh we're gonna mock them mostly
it's mostly going to be mocking them but
first guys i want to talk to you about
policy
genius you know i'm going to be a dad
soon it's on its way it's coming my last
days of freedom are here but that's all
the more reason for a reliable life
insurance plan which of course now seems
more important than ever did you know
that having your life insurance through
your job may not be enough most people
need up to 10 times more coverage to
properly provide for their families
fortunately policy genius is your
one-stop shop to find the insurance you
need at the right price click the link
in the description or head over to
policygenius.comruben and answer a
couple questions in minutes you can
compare personalized quotes from top
companies to find your lowest price you
could save 50 or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
the team of licensed experts at policy
genius are on hand through the entire
process to help you understand your
options and make decisions with
confidence the policy genius team works
for you not the insurance companies
whether you're just starting to shop or
have questions about your active policy
they're your independent
advocates offering unbiased advice
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
or sell your info to third parties they
have thousands of five-star reviews
across google and trustpilot and best of
all policy genius has options that offer
coverage in as little as a week and
avoid unnecessary medical exams head on
over to policygenius.com ruben to get
your free life insurance quote and see
how much you could save and now back to
me all right guys so today the theme is
about the country that is burning that
boys are girls two plus two is five
non-racists or racists and all of this
adds to a situation where the country
feels unstable our entire
system of making sense of any of this
and the people who are supposed to be in
charge the people who are supposed to
communicate to us properly the people
who are supposed to you know institute
policies that hopefully free us and
allow us to live the way we want they're
all doing it backwards basically so
first off fauci remember fauci for two
years this guy got basically everything
wrong often lied publicly compared to
what he was saying privately related to
masks and the rest of it well we know we
know all this well he disappeared for
about a month as covert pretty much went
away but suddenly they're dragging him
back they got him out of the crypt he's
back and he's interested in masking you
again
but the idea that we're going to see an
uptick i think people need to appreciate
that that's the case and follow the cdc
guidelines because remember
when the metrics were put forth the new
metrics looking at the guidance of
masking it was said that if we do start
seeing an uptick particularly of
hospitalizations we may need to revert
back to me being more careful and having
more utilizations of masks in dorm
no sorry i'm never going to listen to
you i am a free man of my own volition
with my own mind and you have lied about
everything the policies that you have
pushed for did no better in california
where they were used to draconianly lock
down people versus the free state in
florida which is the second oldest
population in the united states and the
numbers were not completely out of whack
actually depending on the study in many
cases the numbers in florida were a lot
better on top of the fact that you
didn't destroy people's lives here in
terms of their jobs and their mental
health and everything else but you know
he talks about the new metrics it was
said it was said that if these new
metrics popped up it was said that we
might have to put you in masks again who
said it you
he's quoting himself i said that if the
thing goes up i might have to do no
you're not in charge of us anymore
you're an old buffoon retire go away
nobody likes you
that's how i feel about that but it's
not just uh fouchy
it's not just this fouchy fella who's
back on the sunday morning talk shows
because they need to scare us again
right the scare machine is back we got
midterm elections coming up it looks
like it's going to be a
complete decimation of the democratic
party and we can only hope that that is
the case that is the only way we get
back to some sort of
national sanity in this country um but
they need covid and because they need
kovid you can see it's sort of leaking
back into the system right now so uh
here is uh jen saki
and you literally she's just a liar go i
will tell you that the vice president
has been wearing a mask inside when
there was a private greet they were all
wearing masks uh
before they went out
yesterday at the center
she was
playing an important role in in
confirming or overseeing the
confirmation of the first black woman at
the supreme court
okay so first off um kamala harris does
not wear masks indoors when there's no
cameras obviously
enough of the theater
if you believe that then i've got a
bridge to sell you like look behind the
curtain guys
it ain't this big scary eyes guy it's an
old beat up wizard that's all that's
left okay old beat up failed scientist
it's something like that if you think
kamala harris is doing that let's not
forget it was only a couple weeks ago
that all of those geriatric old buffoons
were all in a windowless
uh
congress right they were all at the
capitol
during the state of the union
and they were hugging and sniffing hair
and doing everything else that they
would do so please
saki you're a liar obviously kamala
harris is not just she just yes she's
always indoors with math is that even
the guidance anymore i'm not even sure
that's the guidance as per that schmuck
fouchy okay that's number one number two
did you catch what she said there at the
end well yesterday she took the mask off
because she was playing an important
role in something so when something's
seriously important when you're got a
black supreme court justice coming in
then of course covid can't be spread
which is the same drivel
that these crazy people were telling you
when they had you masked up but then
there's a black lives matter rally and
we're burning down portland so take off
your mask that's literally what they
were doing remember laurie lightfoot the
uh the spitting image of health remember
when she uh took off her mask so that
she could rally in chicago because you
know we have to do it
we have to do it because if you're
protesting racism you can't get covered
anyway they lie about everything and
they also don't want you to take masks
off on planes which is patently
ridiculous and by the way i'm seeing
more and more people just go ahead and
do it which is that's your right as an
american to fight the power man uh dana
perino my friend dana perino over on fox
she asked sake about the airplane mask
mandate speaking of covet in about eight
days the cdc is supposed to release
information
or release a decision on whether
americans will continue to have to wear
masks on airlines does the president
have a view does he want to see
americans be able to
lift those masks off their faces as they
try to travel and get back to some
normalcy
well the president's gonna wait and see
what the cdc recommends and as you said
we don't have too much more time to wait
for that so we'll we'll learn more in
the coming days
god i really hate her like hate's not
good
i try not to thrive on hate a lot of
people do i don't run with hate but when
we do the run-through of the show we do
a quick run-through where we run through
all the clips i cannot i actually have
to tell the guys okay i got it i can't
even watch her anymore i find her so
vile so soulless and your ability to lie
and just there's nothing real about her
whatsoever so she'll be a perfect host
on msnbc which is where she's going as
you know when she leaves the white house
gig anyway as far as the plane situation
first off saki does not wear masks on
planes let's be clear she's usually
flying on air force one or some other
government plane or private plane and if
you think she's wearing a mask it's the
same thing as joe he gets off the
helicopter they've shown the videos
where he puts the mask on as he gets off
to walk on the grass because he doesn't
even know what he's doing right
they lie about that we're also told
constantly you've all been on a plane
what do they always show you on a plane
they show you either an animation or a
very fake looking person and they've got
spray in the air is 99.999
filtered and it's the safest one
okay so is that is that all just a lie
could anyone release any numbers related
to people that got coveted on planes has
that not been released no no numbers on
that voucher you got any numbers no
nothing
nothing to talk about the point is if
you want to wear a mask on a plane fine
wear a mask i highly recommend it if you
want to put a plastic bubble on your
head
do not drink water do not eat food but
the rest of this is pure [ __ ] covent
can spread whether you're eating peanuts
although peanuts will kill you too on a
plane uh or whether you're having a dry
wrap because the wraps are always dry
aren't they always dry you get to wrap
on a plane it's always dry
a little mayo people
it's all just endless nonsense just
endless nonsense but uh they have fear
that's what this administration has so
here's gay pete he's our uh
transportation secretary only got the
job because he's gay that's the only
reason i say he's gay i don't really
care that he's gay nothing wrong with
that uh here's gate pete he went on the
view which is a show that's actually on
right now at 11 a.m eastern it's a bunch
of crazy women that sit at a table very
bright lights and they just lie about
everything uh he went on to scare people
about uh what could happen to you if you
dare get uppity when you're on a plane
it's one thing to be grumpy on a flight
but i i feel that way sometimes it's a
little further
but yeah it's another thing to endanger
flight crews and to endanger fellow
passengers we have no tolerance for that
the faa is actually getting ready to
announce record fines on people who have
done this oh wow look if you're on an
airplane don't be a jerk don't endanger
your fellow passengers also if you're
not on an airplane don't be
he's afraid a meaningless nothing that's
what pete is he's just a meaningless
suit that is nothing there first off no
one thinks you should be mean on an
airplane there have been plenty of times
on airplanes well by the way first off
the staff on airplanes and these people
have been stressed and it's not the most
fun job in good times um and often
you know passengers aren't the nicest
they're not the nicest it's become a
really toxic place in many ways being on
airplanes like you really never know
that's what i've noticed on planes at
this point you have no idea when you get
on that plane are the staff going to all
be awful are the passengers going to be
angry now first off we have laws related
to how you can behave on planes in
general right we all know this i venture
to say that every one of you watching
this has been on a plane before where
someone's been kicked off a plane or
something has happened i've had
extraordinarily rude flight attendants
and everything else we already have
fines we already have rules related to
this no one's saying that you should be
a dick you may not like the policies i
don't like the policies you may think
that the policies are completely
nonsense i think the policies are
completely nonsense but you can't
verbally abuse somebody you can't
certainly you can't physically abuse
somebody but they're just trying to
scare us more record fines are coming
for you people who don't shut up and who
dare have opinions and show a little
frustration because we're a bunch of
inept morons but it's not just that
right so that's that's a version of
what's going on here that they we just
have people who don't follow their own
policies you all know that
but they're coming for everything it's
not just the planes and they want to
bring masks back as if we didn't learn
anything did you learn anything over
these last two years i learned a little
something but i guess a lot of people
didn't learn something but you may
remember last week we covered a little
bit of video from this disinformation
uh gathering this was the video that i
showed you where
a young student from the university of
chicago uh he basically just nailed
brian stelter he asked him about the
misinformation that they share on cnn
and stelter basically was like well
let's go to lunch um well there's more
video leaking out from this conference
and they had amy klobuchar there you may
remember abe klomachar she ran for
president got about one percent of the
vote then dropped out back biden that's
what you got to do
and now she's involved in misinformation
as it relates to big tech and science
scary pandemics and all of those things
and listen to the question here related
to health misinformation and listen to
her answer you introduced the bill that
you talked about today that would punish
social media companies like facebook and
twitter for
having health misinformation on their
platforms
and i'm going to ask you if i were to
say
that there are only two sexes
male and female
would that be considered misinformation
that you think should be banned uh
speech on social media platforms
okay i'm not going to get into what
misinformation first of all i think the
bill you're talking about is different
than the one we've mostly been talking
about so i want to make that clear we've
been talking about the competition bill
but there is another bill that i have on
vaccine misinformation it is that
specific in a public health crisis you
wonder why you get that specific um it's
because we're trying to find carve outs
that i did with this was with ben ray
lujan
that got to
that you can't have immunity as a social
media company if you are broadcasting
vaccine
misinformation
truth coming this way
off-ramp yeah of course you can't answer
the question the basic purpose of the
question are there biological
differences between men and women the
democrat party at this point has no one
as far as i know in the party that can
say that men and women are different
i'm not a biologist but it's something
like this
men have penises women have vaginas
this is this is the most incredible show
we've ever done i really feel that i'm
pushing the limits of what thank you got
a thumbs up over there uh they cannot
stop themselves these people because
they lie everything that they do every
policy that they bring in everything
that they want this country to be is
based on their power hungry destruction
of
reality that's what it is so she can't
answer whether if you say that a man is
a man and a woman is a woman and these
are two distinct different things
whether you'll be banned from social
media whether she would be for that and
then she basically gives this sort of
broad nothingness answer related to
misinformation when it comes to
covid in essence is what they're talking
about because they're talking about
science misinformation and what should
happen to these big tech companies and
yet we know
that if you were going to be banning
people
for covet misinformation you'd have to
ban joe biden who said if you take the
vaccine you will not get or transmit
covet you'd have to ban everybody that's
involved with these this clown car of
stupidity but here's gay pete again he
went on he was on the viewing same video
from before same segment and and just
listen to the lies listen to the lies i
mean it they train them i don't know
where these people get media training
you see how klobuchar what she just did
there was she was asked a very direct
question she deflected the question
answered something else completely watch
pete when the lunatics at the view
ask pete about bill
hb1557 which is what they call the don't
say gay bill but of course as you know
could just as easily be called the don't
say straight bill your husband chaston
is a teacher
and he's been a vocal critic of what's
going on in my state of florida when the
with the so-called don't say gay
law now um which
he says will kill kids do you agree
and you know as a politician because
this this
strikes you as you know your husband is
a teacher
you are uh
obviously lgbtq yourself and you are now
a parent yeah
so how do you feel yeah he's right and
and i think every law to be judged for
the effect it's going to have on real
people in real life and i i get the
political reasons why they're doing this
by the way some of those political
reasons
they don't have a plan on anything else
right i mean they they don't have a plan
on dealing with inflation or or dealing
with with gas prices or dealing with the
issues we can't get home insurance in
florida we're banning all sorts of
conversations easier right it's easier
politically but this is going to hurt
people
nothing he is nothing he's not a man
he's not a man
he's he's a pretend man in a well-fitted
suit that's all he is so let's just go
through each one first off
uh what's her name anna navarro what a
horrible human being she is uh she says
chaston's a teacher the implication that
just because he's a teacher he should
have some authority to discuss sex and
gender identity with your kids so what
he's a teacher so what i don't know what
he what's he a teacher of can we find
out what he's a teacher of i don't care
if he's a history teacher he should be
teaching history if he's a math teacher
he should be teaching math if he's a
science teacher including a biology
teacher he should be teaching biology
and if he's a grade school teacher there
are basic uh learning
blocks of education that he should be
learning or have the kids building
blocks that would be fine in an
elementary school as well but he has no
right to talk about gender identity or
sexuality with a second grader okay so
that's that's number one uh
that chaston says that this is going to
kill kids that bill hb1557 is going to
kill kids and and p agrees yeah that's
right peter agrees it's going to kill
kids so if kids if second graders
seven-year-olds can't discuss gender
identity with the state employee and
have that state employee hide it from
the parents that's going to kill them
complete lie complete lie but again all
they can do is lie about everything
apparently he's a humanities teacher and
a theater teacher oh isn't that and a
diversity teacher
now i think you're punking me he's a
humanities teacher a theater teacher and
a diversity club teacher
then navarro says that uh she says to
pete you're lgbtq yourself so that
implies
that pete is a lesbian okay so pete is a
lesbian check pete is gay lg gay okay
he's gay got it he's bi he's bisexual so
he's banging chicks on the side i wonder
if chad chaston knows that uh he's trans
pete is trans also that is something
else and you know with these well fitted
suits like get this gala dress you know
what i'm talking about and q which i
honestly don't know what it is
apparently he's a conspiracy theorist
he's some mega far right q anonymous
he's just awful oh and then oh and then
then the best part of this
why are they pushing these bills pil
pete says they're pushing them because
they have no plans on inflation and gas
prices
actually
dave donkers actually gay pete
it's your administration it's your boss
that is printing money out of control
that is causing inflation it's your
idiotic policies related to keystone
pipeline your administration
related to keystone related to
everything you've done that have
destroyed the economy okay it's you guys
that have done all this what does that
have to do with the governor what does
flor what does florida's governor have
to do with inflation throughout the
country what does florida's governor
have to do with gas prices throughout
the country actually gas prices are way
better in florida than they are in
california okay you you're just you lie
about everything oh and then that wizard
uh navarro says that you can't get home
insurance in florida i have literally no
idea what she's talking about i just got
here i just got to florida i had to get
home insurance you're not going to
believe what i did guys this was
incredible you'll be homeowners one day
i picked up the phone and i called an
insurance company and i got a couple of
quotes and then i picked the best rate
it's [ __ ] extraordinary anna navarro
i have to we have to get this clip to
navarro she's living with no home
insurance okay the woman i'm actually
told i live somewhat close to her
wouldn't that be horrible if i saw her
on the street that would be
anyway gate pete continued he's making
the rounds you know instead of doing
work he's he's making the rounds and he
was on charlemagne he said charlemagne
the god is that what they call them the
god that's a
dave reuben
the god
he's on charlemagne the god he's got a
radio show i guess and uh charlemagne
tells pete pete black people don't like
you
you do realize pete um a lot of black
people feel like democrats have kept no
promises
since they've been in since they've been
in office really yes reverend island
said that a million times let me show
you i mean pressing you okay
look i get it
one more time
you do realize pete um
a lot of black people feel like
democrats have kept no promises
since they've been in since they've been
in office really yes
reverend island said that a million
times let me show you i mean pressing
you okay
look i get it
really yes look i get it
i get it
yes you don't
do you don't keep your promises
democrats actually instill all of the
policies that have kept black people
more impoverished let's say than white
people or whatever phrase you want to
use on that the welfare state which
destroyed the black family and then
keeps people in in generational poverty
rita thomas sober really really but i
say i like black people we're lgbt we're
black we're everything we got a little
bit of everything we love everybody
because we're always talking about
everybody
god these people
anyway they are they're just everything
lying so what do we got here what do we
got we got there the lying about covid
the lying about the gender stuff and
then of course and this will
bring us home here
the lying about race which is exactly
what that was they lie about race
remember donald trump that orange man
spoke at the state of the union and
talked about all-time low black
unemployment and the congressional black
caucus sat there like this
oh you think we're supposed to applaud
low black unemployment you're orange man
we ain't gonna do it okay
liars and evil freaks that's what they
are uh
but i guess at some level at some level
it was in terms of pure optics and
nothing having to do with the law it was
a good week i suppose for the optics
related uh to black people in america
something like that uh that katanji
brown jackson was confirmed and there
was a big
celebration the first black woman to the
united states supreme court
whoa
it's about time i know where i am for a
second it's a miracle i can't believe it
just so i can pander with that other
horrible woman okay so then biden took
the stage and here's where it gets fun
biden just completely completely makes
up what happened during katanji brown
jackson's confirmation hearing i knew
the person i nominated will be put
through a painful and difficult
confirmation process
but i have to tell you
what judge jackson has put through
was well beyond that
there was verbal abuse the anger
the constant interruptions
the most vile baseless assertions and
accusations
in the face of it all
judge jackson showed the incredible
character and integrity she possesses
poise
[Applause]
poison composure
patience and restraint
and yes perseverance and even joy
even joy
these pandering people these pandering
people so he said three things there
that i thought were pretty interesting
and you know we like to do our research
here he said there was verbal abuse
he said there was anger directed toward
katanji bow jackson and vile baseless
assertions so i said to my guys this
morning i said guys we must find video
on this we must find video do we have
internet access i was told that we do
and they all went on their computer
machines and each one of them they sat
privately in different rooms i said you
guys i don't want you to infect each
other
influence each other in any way whole
team of people we had we had 100 people
100 staff members all trying in
different rooms on the computer
connected to the internet trying to find
any level of anger
verbal abuse or vile baseless assertions
that were sent her way we didn't find
any of that but we did find her not
knowing what a woman was can you provide
a definition for the word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me a
definition
senator in my work as a judge what i do
is i
address disputes if there's a dispute
about a definition people make arguments
and i look at the law and i decide so
i'm not
the fact that you
can't give me a straight answer about
something as fundamental
as what a woman is underscores the
dangers of the kind of progressive
education
that we are hearing about
i'm not a psychologist but i know what
pure [ __ ] is when someone's spewing
it okay
so yes do you think that this is a
problem i get it and as i said last week
you know generally speaking when the
president nominates a supreme court
justice unless they have like really
horrific glaringly awful decisions to
look back at that seemingly are
completely against the constitution that
in essence they should
pass through the senate there's there's
a cursory look at them but of course
unfortunately in the last 30 or so years
this process got highly politicized it
was highly politicized really at first
by a guy by the name of joe biden and
we'll have more on that in just a second
but in essence she should get through
whether sort of whether you like her or
not right the democrats aren't going to
like brett kavanaugh the republicans
aren't going to like katanji brown
jackson each one of them lean a certain
way in their uh in their jurisprudence
related to how they how they analyze the
law et cetera et cetera how they look at
the constitution okay fine
um
but as i said there are some optics to
this and and katangi brown jackson
actually hit on some of these optics um
by quoting maya angelou when she was uh
talking during the press conference
to be sure i have worked hard to get to
this point in my career and i have now
achieved something far beyond anything
my grandparents could have possibly ever
imagined
but no one
does this on their own
the path was cleared for me
so that i might rise to this occasion
and in the poetic words of dr maya
angelou
i do so now while
bringing the gifts
my ancestors gave
i
am the dream and the hope
of the slave
okay at some level that's actually quite
nice right that's quite nice that
someone
um
who is the same skin color as a slave in
america could rise up and and make it to
the supreme court that's quite
extraordinary it actually tells you
really how wonderful this country is how
amazing equality is and that we've had
by the way uh black supreme court
justices before i believe it was
politico a few days ago that tweeted out
that she'll be the first black supreme
court justice of course that's not true
but uh yeah we've had them before and we
will have them again and frankly i don't
care about a supreme court's uh
justice's color or sexuality or anything
else but she is quite right that there's
something nice about that and that made
us think well well wait a minute we've
had some black supreme court justices on
before and how did how did people like
joe biden treat them
during their confirmation hearing
because i suspect
perhaps it
might not be exactly the way joe would
have you think it was
this is a case in which this sleaze
this dirt
was searched for by
staffers of members of this committee
was then leaked
to the media
and this committee
and this body
validated it
and displayed it
at prime time
over our entire nation this is a circus
it's a national disgrace
and from my standpoint
as a black american as far as i'm
concerned it is a high-tech lynching
for uppity blacks
who in any way deign to think for
themselves
we already have a mayor we don't need
any more big shots
okay so obviously that was clarence
thomas during his confirmation hearing
uh and he mainly he's going after mostly
democrats there obviously but very much
focused on joe biden actually
and if you want more on just joe biden's
history going after supreme court
nominees just google uh joe biden and
robert bork okay
um
so
it's not that joe biden is for black
people or democrats or for black people
there are four people who behave they
way they want them to behave
nobody in america really except for
modern democrats progressives leftists
cares about your skin color nobody cares
they're just nobody is nobody cares it's
all they got left it's all they got left
so pandering joe biden congratulations
you you i guess in your myopic world
view look like mr tolerance and
non-racist or something because a black
woman is on the supreme court but just
remember nobody really cared and you
tried to destroy
uh one black man who tried to get on the
supreme court about 30 some odd years
ago by the way you may remember we
played this clip last week nancy pelosi
alcoholic geriatric nancy pelosi she
said last week that she never thought
that clarence thomas should have been
put on the supreme court in the first
place so i guess she's racist by the
modern thinking of the democrat party
ladles and jelly spoons today is monday
and that means that it is meme monday
over at the reuben report community
here's the meme that i put up this
morning
instead of worrying how this guy spends
his money
elon musk you should worry how they are
spending
yours
government
people spending your money poorly we are
we have an odd obsession with saying
that if we just took out the billionaire
class and stole all of their money or
made them poor or took all their money
away that it would solve anything and no
the government doesn't need more of
anyone's money the government the
government needs to stop spending your
money it's a spending problem not an
income
problem and we got hundreds more in
there so if you want to join us for me
monday or if you want to chat during the
show uh you can join us at ruben
report.locals.com we've got a cold
clothes for you so hang on uh real quick
couple locals comments it's nice to know
this is m says it's nice to know a woman
who cannot define herself has been
appointed to the highest court in the
country i think i need a drink right so
they're going on and on this is very
exciting we've got the first black woman
but if you ask her what a woman is she
has no freaking clue irony is truly dead
uh pete fight fits right in with the
view shows how absurd he is yeah
he's just nothing you know what i mean
by that like when when you look at sake
it's like okay here she is she lies
about everything and and
i just don't know what that is i've
mentioned this on the show a few times
and i've seen some comments really and
it's like i just don't know how you
could live like that right it's not to
say i've never lied right like of course
i've lied everyone has lied everyone has
made mistakes everyone has dealt in ways
that they're not proud of all of those
things but if it is your if it is your
main driver to be a pusher of propaganda
and lies i just don't know how how that
i can't imagine like the soul rot i
honestly cannot imagine it so that's
sake but then you have a guy like pete
who's just nothing you're just you just
say what the machine wants you to say
and it's all meaningless yes
don't say gay bill which isn't even
don't say gay bill is going to cause
kids to be killed no it isn't
oh yes they're really pushing don't say
gay because they have no plans on
inflation it's your
job buffoon
okay because gas prices have a little
something to do with the uh secretary of
transportation dragon hawk says dave
doesn't uh dave just doesn't have any
pity for us on a monday morning in
reference to the sake clip maybe on
mondays there should be a warning uh
connor can you remember that going
forward on mondays let's have some sort
of warning we're going to be showing jen
saki it's not a great way to start off
the week prepare yourself something like
that there should be more warnings on
the show in general
i feel good about today guys this is a
huge week for us obviously around here
my guys have been busting their butts
we're super psyched about the launch of
the book tomorrow apparently books are
showing up today you can get your copy
of don't burn this country at
daverubin.com
book you can pick it up at bookstores
tomorrow or you can get it online today
for delivery tomorrow and i'm going on
tour and i hope that you guys will join
me out there dave rubin.com
events and a whole bunch of great people
from dennis prager larry elder megan
kelly a bunch of my friends will be
joining me playing around with the with
the q a and we'll throw some stuff in
the crowd and it's going to be fun and
silly and sometimes serious it's going
to be a little bit of what we do right
here on the reuben report program my
full interview with david mamet by the
way playwright author
screenwriter really fantastic interview
people are really digging it
is up on youtube and rumble and blaze tv
locals the whole shebang uh and finally
we leave you
with the elderly man pretending to be
president of the united states i was
going to foot him
excuse me the foothills of the himalayas
with xi jinping
traveling with him
unless we travel 17 000 miles when i was
vice president i don't know that for a
fact
good morning good morning
good morning america